good morning everyone can you hear me
the decoration of the results home
elected from a member of parliament for
Queens central I tell you that's a
narrow room in the returning officer at
the pub election do hereby give notice
that the number of votes recorded for
each candidate and the said election is
as follows Barbara
Gavin Florence for the Conservative
Party candidate twenty four thousand two
hundred and twenty one
Parramatta commonly known as broaden
John Christian people's lives 177 hey
Tracy Jo green party 626 absurd so you
know Cecily
commonly known as vixen and Jill for the
Liberal Democrat Party 1083 James Sarah
and commonly known as James Sarah for
the Labour Party 29 though
[Applause]
look London commonly known has locked on
independent 71 votes slavery Peters the
UK Independence Party
you get one thousand and forty votes a
number of other papers rejected ours
follow what I want of an official mark
zero voting for more than one candidate
thirty-nine writing or bark by which
voted would be identified two big on
marked a worry and avoid process G 68
total rejected papers 109 the electorate
was eighty thousand and forty five bad
papers issued fifty seven thousand two
hundred and four turnout seventy one
point five seven
[Applause]
I declare that Sarah and Jones is duly
elected
[Applause]
people affordance between that - in me
and in the United Labor Party's
[Applause]
collection turned out folks today shows
how much people care about their time I
want to thank that all of the documented
a possible working here working at the
polling stations and the police of the
security and anyone who's waited a and
success and I want to pay tribute
together bar well within seven years
service as Jennifer winter
you know it all started here a few weeks
ago when Jeremy Corbyn launched his
campaign in Croydon and since then we
have seen literally thousands of people
from Croydon and across London
come to help us in our campaign the
energy that they have brought us has
helped us on our way to talk to over
25,000 what are people opponents have
told us is that you know they want first
funded fairly they want us to cherish
our NHS they want our young people to
have opportunities in life and they want
us to respect our older people in
retirement but the most interesting
thing I'd stood in 2015 the most
interesting difference between 2015 and
now it is young people young people one
is the lecture immature because they
came out with first time and wanted to
vote they wanted to vote for Jeremy
Corbyn they wanted to vote for our
manifesto and they wanted to vote for
their own futures tonight young people
have taken back control yeah
that is as it should be but we all have
to take that very seriously and we have
them agree play from exacting by living
their life chances that they deserve
today I think people already voted for
hope and whoever however anybody voted
today I think we're all united by
wanting what's best for boredom which we
know is the most fantastic town